he will open them up like that these
flaps will assist you in opening up the
glove so you won't contaminate them and
just pull it open and remember you have
two inches to grab around this field my
dominant hand is my right hand so I'm
going to glove that first grab the cuff
of the right part of the glove slightly
tuck my thumb in slide my hand in
and then just put my fingers out and
then I'm just going to roll that down
making sure I don't touch the outer part
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
just sliding underneath I'm going to
make sure I keep this thumb away because
I'm going to slide it over my left hand
tuck my left thumb in again and just
slide underneath the glove and I'm
pushing with this part of the glove so
it'll go over my hand
gently roll it down without touching my
arm and I have the gloves on and they
are steriles